I think you're going to love this next
segment one of the big revelations of
the last 10 days in the American
political world is that a Republican
congressman named Devin Nunez is part of
the problem rather than being someone
investigating the problem what I mean by
that is Devin Nunez was part of that
group that was having meetings in Europe
looking for dirt on Joe Biden
encouraging others to smear Joe Biden
all with the goal of getting foreign
help in Donald Trump's re-election
campaign it just so happens that Devin
Nunez is also on the House Intelligence
Committee so in the impeachment hearings
from two weeks ago three weeks ago
Devin Nunez was getting to ask questions
of witnesses when in reality he should
be a witness he is actually more of a
co-conspirator rather than an
investigator but over the last week it's
actually gotten even worse there is now
a call log which shows that Devin Nunez
was directly in touch on his phone with
not only Rudy Giuliani Donald Trump's
lawyer who's been spearheading lots of
this insanity but also with a guy named
Lev harness left harness is one of rudy
giuliani's key henchmen in this entire
thing and Lev Parnas along with Igor
Froman were arrested while trying to
flee to Europe on one-way tickets
they've since been indicted Lev Parnas
is now cooperating with investigators
and says he was in touch with Devon
Nunez and he can demonstrate that Devon
Nunez was part of this entire thing so
now we get this call log and the call
log corroborates there was contact
between Nunez and Parnas there was
contact between Nunez and juni Giuliani
and the whole lot of them so that gets
us to a segment on Fox News yesterday I
really really love this there's a guy
named Greg Jarrett that's Greg with two
g's in case you're gonna google that
who's been on Fox News for a very long
time and Donald Trump loves greg jarrett
he has been talking up greg jarrett for
months you will very often see donald
trump retweet quote legal analyses from
greg jarrett from a guy named mark levin
and from some other people and Trump
says Greg Jarrett is really the guy who
understands what's going on he
understands
that I did nothing wrong and Gregg
Jarrett is going to be able to explain
it all to you so asked about this call
log which shows that indeed left Parnas
and devon new nests and rudy guiliani
devon newness was in touch with them and
he's really more a part of the problem
than someone who can be investigating
what went on Jaret suggests on Fox News
this is just amazing without any
evidence he says you know even the call
log might not really corroborate
anything because someone might have used
Devon new necess phone to make those
phone calls this is the most absurd that
we've reached the limit of motivated
reasoning
we've reached the peak of baseless
speculation and just an abundant
violation of the principle of Occam's
razor which I'll get to in a second
check out what gregg jarrett had to say
the only thing new that i picked out of
yesterday's was this communication
between Devon Nunez Rudy Giuliani in the
White House in what way if any is that
problematic what we just don't know
because we don't know the details in
fact it's a call law does that mean that
Devon newness was actually on the call
or somebody else and we don't know the
import of it you know I frankly don't
trust Adam Schiff so absent any evidence
Jaret introduces this idea maybe someone
took Devon Nunez his phone to make those
phone calls or I guess even less
believable would be maybe Nunez said to
someone here take my phone and call left
parlor harness and Rudy Guiliani
whatever version you are believing is
what Gregg Jarrett is suggesting doesn't
make any sense now
fiction has become reality on Tuesday
when the call log leaked I saw tweets
sort of I thought jokingly saying
they're gonna come up with something
like it wasn't really Devon unas using
the phone or the call log was spoofed or
someone hacked his phone to make the
phone calls and it really wasn't Devon
Nunez and then yesterday Gregg Jarrett
actually pulls that idea on national
television and suggests it and the most
troubling thing about it I know you know
where I'm going is that some people are
going to fall for it not definitively
but it'll give them enough plausible
deniability so that even though there's
no evidence
they will say well okay it looks like
the call log corroborates what left
Parnas said but do we know for sure that
that was Devon Nunez on the phone in the
same way that I might have been coerced
into saying something on this show could
you really believe what is what I'm
saying on this show really what I think
or did someone hold me at gunpoint just
off-camera and forced me to do it I
guess it's possible but absent any
evidence why would we go to that Occam's
razor which explanation fits what we
know with the fewest assumptions well
Devon Nunez is known to be super sketchy
left Parnas says he was in touch with
Nunez the call record says Parnas was in
touch with Nunez or maybe someone took
Devon knew neces phone and called
exactly the people that left Parnas says
Nunez was in touch with in order to
falsely incriminate Devon unas or for
some other reason this is a suggestion
that should be laughed away until
someone can come up with some evidence
but otherwise we're in the world of Wow
someone might fall for this well then
let's say it and see who we pull in and
unfortunately when you're dealing with
low information trumpets you're going to
pull some people in with this nonsense
incredible we'll follow up on this with
a clip on our Instagram page at david
pakman show on instagram make sure
you're following us there while you're
there follow me on instagram - why would
i i'm posting stuff - at david pakman
we'll take a quick break we'll be back
right after this with dr. John Gartner
with a new report and then much more
later on in the program before you go on
to the next video please hit subscribe
and like we are trying to figure out
what this will do for helping us in
YouTube's algorithm I will report back
to you but please before you go on to
the next video please subscribe to our
Channel and hit that like button thank
you